[Musique]
ça fait trois ans que macro un président
de la république et que finalement il
s'est peu exprimé sur ces sujets et qui
là et qu'on a peu avancé vous savez
qu'en donne de la sécurité le en même
temps ça peut pas marcher
il faut la naïveté du ministre de la
justice pour considérer que l'insécurité
ne se développe pas que c'est simplement
un sentiment que j'ai envie de dire à
monsieur dupont moretti les dans quel
monde vit t-il pour ignorer cette
réalité qui est celle des français tous
les chiffres l'attestent
il ya une augmentation de la délinquance
dans notre pays qui explose qui explose
je vous le dis et notamment sur la
dernière année et donc on a des faits de
délinquance pourquoi parce que d'abord
l'autorité recul la sécurité c'est la
première des libertés
le gouvernement n'a que trop tardé à
traiter ces questions feront mots mais
faible en actes aujourd'hui le problème
de monsieur damas qui n'a pas de vision
pour la sécurité il n'a pas de dents il
nous donne pas d'instruction moi
j'attends des actes très concret et on
ne peut pas tout demander aux policiers
il faut qu'il y ait surtout une réponse
pénale je suis étonné qu'on puisse
d'ailleurs manifesté dans le contexte
que vous évoquez que nous évoquons tout
rassemblement est un rassemblement qui
présentent un risque sanitaire
on voit bien que la réalité dans notre
pays ce n'est pas un sentiment
d'insécurité c'est l'insécurité au
quotidien et donc le gouvernement le
devoir de donner des réponses ses
réponses elles doivent être fermes
elle doit elle d'octets proportionnée
mais extrêmement forte que je regrette
c'est que pourquoi le gouvernement n'a
pas mis l'été à profit pour tout
préparer en cette rentrée
je ne sais pas vous mais moi je n'y
comprends rien au fond nous avons des
dirigeants qui ne savent plus diriger
jean castex ne s'est pas fixé de cap et
on voit bien que patauge dans la semoule
depuis plusieurs semaines sur la
question des tests sur la question des
mesures à prendre parce qu'ils n'ont pas
le courage prend des décisions qu'il
faut prendre
il n'y a plus de courage alors nous
n'accepterons pas leur confinement
parce qu'il était juste il est incapable
de le faire et on a eu vingt capable de
le faire réaliser au niveau local il est
incohérent et n'a pas de stratégie et
donc que je regrette c'est qu'on
attendait d
réponses précises à des sujets précis on
va en parler probablement tous les deux
et on a eu essentiellement des
commentaires a peut-être une exception
près qui est qu'on a appris qu'on allait
embaucher deux mille personnes pour
poursuivre les gens positifs
bon bah voilà on va mettre plus de 1000
personnes dans les ars je ne suis pas
certain que ça arrive le problème
d'autant que je me souviens qu'au mois
de mai on nous avait dit qu'il n'aurait
30000 d'embauché donc je ne sais pas
aurait été où on en est ce que les 2007
en plus et rendez vous quand même avoir
en tête qu'on a abordé cette liste dans
une situation de faiblesse
contrairement ce que que des
gouvernements situation de faiblesse sur
le plan du chômage situation de
faiblesse sur le plan de la dette
sur le plan des déficits etc et sur le
plan de la dépense donc les réformes
n'avaient pas été faits dans mais vous
croyez qu'il a que les français en ont
pas marre ça fait des décennies qu'on
annonce des plans 10 milliards 50
milliards 100 milliards c'est l'argent
de qui d'abord c'est l'argent des fort
des français c'est l'argent des
contribuables pour moi ce plan il doit
permettre à hauteur de ces milliards
d'engager une transformation notre
économie notamment sur les questions
écologiques sur les questions
d'environnement
la vraie relance se serait en réalité
que la france soit réformée dans
d'autres pays a pas d'énorme plan de
relance je leur ai fait lire notre pays
à la fois le co vide et un autre virus
lui qui n'a pas de vaccin et qui
s'appelle la confiance tout cela la
confiance nous devons la rétablir et je
ne vois que l'élection présidentielle
pourrait à un moment où nous pouvons
engager le train de réformes nécessaires
dans notre pays a besoin que la droite
doit avoir un candidat en 2022 parce que
ce qui se prépare en ce moment
wisair que ce dont rêve monsieur macron
c'est de se retrouver face à marine le
pen
quel autre parti politique peut réunir
plus d'un millier de jeunes durant deux
journées pour réfléchir à l'écologie à
l'europe à l'ascenseur social durant
deux jours nous sommes le seul parti
politique de ce pays
avoir pu réunir un millier de jeunes au
que nous trouvions rapidement une
incarnation pour porter les valeurs de
la droite républicaine et ses valeurs
elles sont plébiscités plus que jamais
dans le pays
[Musique]